Aparri gotten a move on on this man
Paris is a food lover's delight if
you're looking for something tasty it
won't take you long to find it here the
Marais district in the heart of Paris is
home to the city's oldest covered market
the mall she does all phone bouche named
after the red uniforms worn by the
children who lived in an orphanage which
used to occupy the site
in the midst of all the bustle lies a
special find a stand run by a local sir
allowance here from Wednesday through
Sunday
he runs a crap and sandwich bar together
with his son who handles the bakery
products
they say I make the best Colette's in
Paris
from the start my idea was to produce a
quality product something really good
the people love water and salt to the
batter legs and a drop of olive oil we
try to use organic ingredients as far as
possible you can order a vegan galette
with mushrooms avocado and toasted
sesame seeds or one with ham cheese and
salad
or the traditional version with lemon
and sugar
like head sugared crepes are very French
galleta brittle they're from Brittany so
they're not traditionally French in the
same way allow has many loyal customers
and is always winning over new collect
fans from all over the world
local Parisians know the best time of
day to come round on Sunday mornings
there's no wait
by midday you can take quarter of an
hour and after that can be even longer
so nice but it's well worth the wait
Bon Appetit